welcome back to CBS mornings we are very
excited for a very special we were just
sitting here talking I know we're at the
top of the table which is happening
right now was already happening while we
were in the commercial break we are
joined by Drew Barrymore host of The
Drew Barrymore Show and her Drew's news
co-host Ross Matthews yes welcome to you
both what's going on
thank you you're always so happy to be
here being the news men and women that
we are
[Laughter]
so top of the table is where we bring
stories that are the talk of this table
you guys are joining us what do you have
all right well
um let's see okay my talk of the table
is exciting new Innovations in the
makeup industry now as a beauty junkie I
get excited about these things cosmetic
giant L'Oreal for which I am a Garnier
Ambassador I might mention unveiled
prototypes for two first of their kind
products at this year's Consumer
Electronics Show the first is a smart
eyebrow makeup applicator now it uses an
app to scan your face oh how then it
recommends different eyebrow shapes
colors and thickness once you decide on
a brow you move the printer across your
eyebrows and voila 24 tiny little
nozzles 2400 print the eyebrow makeup
right on your face oh wow now the second
product is the world's first handheld
and computerized lipstick applicator
it's designed for people with limited
fine motor skills it uses a combination
of motor controls and customizable
attachments to level the lipstick for
steady application and L'Oreal says
inclusivity is at the heart of their
Innovation I love this now when I first
heard this drawer I thought how does
technology and makeup work together but
now I see it I thought it sounds like a
lot of work but it really isn't they
will put the brow on for you it takes
the workout yeah I don't like that it
scans your face though because what if
it scans your face and says girl there's
nothing I can do for you
I can't do that Ross
in 2001. sorry for you well I want to
talk about this story it's my talk of
the table it's a tick tock video of a
mother and a son that had me feeling all
the feelings you know I'm a Mama's Boy
Take a look at this it's a video that
shows the mother on her wedding day
doing a first look with her son seeing
each other before they walk down the
aisle now and both of them struggle to
hold back the tears when they see each
other look at this and try to keep it
together
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
happy tears promise you promise
[Music]
oh my gosh when he said my mom I'm just
so happy so happy for you I'm glad he
said that Ross because I was kind of
concerned
are these happy yes
I'm glad he said that yeah what she's
really thinking is don't make me cry I'm
wearing white get away you know but my
makeup's already done exactly but he was
overwhelmed seeing her he was happy for
us so happy seeing his mom so so happy
so happy we're always so concerned for
our kids but when you get that gift of
knowing they're happy for you
all right replace that well my talk the
table is another video that gets you all
of the feels it's a really touching
moment between a father and his son who
was upset with this fourth place finish
in a spelling bee and mom caught it all
on camera
why are you crying
[Music]
from India
that's good for me
and 30 something kids you be out of 5th
graders
proud of you
to get you something okay
and while you hear mom sharing the
encouraging words you can see that Dad
is also tearing up and validating his
son's feelings dad is letting the boy
know that it's okay to cry and feel bad
and none of this has been lost on people
watching this on Tick Tock and all
across social media because they're
applauding the dad for leading with his
heart instead of going over there and
saying man up you'll be all right he
says you know what I'ma share these
tears with you because I understand your
feelings also in encouraging a son who
came in fourth place and he's
disappointed to still say you did a
really good job I think that's so I
think that's a very important message
and the fact that he's crying as you say
validating the feelings that his son has
and saying it's okay to be like this and
get him next time I love that too yeah
you can do both you can be emotional and
also push your son and say get him next
time yeah and Spelling's not everything
but i i l u v this
you'll be all right Ross she'll be great
you'll be perfect perfect all right my
talk at the table uh is a new Guinness
World Record that has some Foodies
scratching their heads let me tell you
about it New Yorker Eric Finkelstein set
the record for the most michelin-starred
restaurants visited in 24 hours this is
crazy he ate at 18 restaurants in one
day he's 18 Gail 18 restaurants in one
day he says it took 14 months of
planning and costs close to 500 which
isn't that much at a Michelin star I
know because what did he eat
so so let me just let me break it down
Keith Michelin star restaurants uh some
of them needed reservations some of the
places were closed down before uh he
could go straight to look for others uh
and there's a catch to qualify for the
World Record he could only use public
transportation or walk no cabs no bikes
allowed he made it to all 18 restaurants
within 11 hours and I love the quote
from the general manager of sushi bar
NoDa here in New York City he says quote
this is an absurd idea born out of the
pursuit of indulgence and in service of
unbridled vanity we are 100 in
I'm like the next time a job opening uh
starts and opens for uh as much as you
can eat in one day and have that
celebrated
we got a brand new career yeah anything
big he ate like bowls of cherries
clearly
I mean lingonberries at one of the
restaurants which is I think a 25 meal
I don't know if that's the same my
chocolate table is just fun Ben Affleck
I love Ben Affleck taking on a new role
that really let him connect with his
audience some Dunkin Donuts Duncan they
don't call it Dunkin Donuts and Duncan
customers in Medford Massachusetts got
quite the surprise the other day when
the Oscar winner himself handed out
their orders at the drive-through window
he was even in uniform now Reports say
that Ben was filming a commercial for
the chain possibly for the Super Bowl
and he wasn't alone wife Jennifer Lopez
but what's so funny is there's other
shots where you see Jennifer actually
driving up to the window in a great car
placing an order I just think they're a
fun couple oh my God if I can't wait to
see the commercial oh yeah to the window
imagine oh you're on the drive through
and they're there I'd be like whoever's
behind me you got to wait because I
gotta I gotta talk to these two I mean
this story is so fun it really is you
brought the good Gail because I've been
seeing photographs of this and wanting
to know what it was all about and now I
know and I love it and y'all brought the
goods thank you yes Drew Barrymore and
Ross man don't be strangers Drew
Barrymore show airs weekdays on stations
around the country to check your local
listings yeah you can find the show